alex is with us in Nebraska hi Alex
welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
I read it on the spine Friday better
than I deserve sir how can I help
all right so I am a full time college
student working the part-time living on
my own and I'm barely scraping by right
now and I'm just kind of curious what
you would say when it comes to paying
off school while working and living on
your own paying off school paying social
or paying as I go a lot you know cash
flowing school as you go along
yeah that's what I'm paying for about
half of semester like half of each
semester of the other half and loves
okay so what is the semester cost um
between forty five hundred and five
grand roughly okay and so you're
borrowing the other two or three
thousand per semester
yes generally it's about twenty five
hundred semester okay and you live on
campus or what I live on my own in
apartment with two roommates okay and
how much is your rent after utilities
it's about 350 Emma okay and what what
are you earning when you're working um
generally it's around 750 bucks a month
or about 8,000 a year during school then
I'll do startup in the summer and pay
off some other stuff okay well what I
would tell you is your your job stinks
you need a different job okay you can
deliver pizzas four nights a week and
make $1,500 a month okay you're making
$700 a month and that would be the
difference in you not going into debt to
pay for this you've got very inexpensive
tuition where are you going to college
uh University of Nebraska its $4,500 so
it's $9,000 a year roughly yeah that's
about right that's abouts normal state
school so what are you doing what what's
your job um right now
time as a server at a assistant assisted
living and memory care facility you know
and I make about 12 an hour yeah just
not making money that's a problem okay
so I mean dude you can buy a lawnmower
and cut grass and make a lot more I'd do
that on the side occasionally but it is
not so 20 right now so yeah so it means
snow blower in the winter right but the
my point is is that there's a whole lot
of different things you can do that'll
make you a lot more money than what
you're making and work more hours okay
and I think you know here's the thing
we're talking about five hundred bucks a
month completely changes this whole
picture doesn't it yeah and so we've got
to fit you know what you've got is
retool your your job idea what you're
doing for your job and typically it's
gonna be something that has a bit of a
self-employment to it okay rather than
just going and clocking in and making
you know seven eight ten twelve dollars
I mean it can be a dog walking service I
don't care if you have talked to several
young people that are really good at
doing online stuff and so they they
literally are making a couple of three
couple of grand 3 grand a month as a
part-time gig building websites for
small businesses those kinds of things
so I don't care what your talents are
what are you studying
I am advertising public relations right
now I wonder if there's not asked some
sad gig hustle stuff you could do for
someone in the PR world I've actually
looked into a son like that under shop
so I'd probably helped him and he'd pay
me a little bit and then I could also
look at some local businesses yeah I
mean anything you know whether you did
it out whether you did it as a side
hustle self-employed but if there's a
good publicity or PR firm in the area
that doesn't want to pay somebody hourly
but instead I'll pay them say listen you
you call these 73 things and we'll give
you X number of dollars and you do that
on your own
I'm and you get some of these things
some of these articles pushed out or
whatever it is they're trying to do that
they can outsource to you as a 1099 but
you can make up make a lot more than you
can you know throwing dishes at the
assisted living thing and so again I
appreciate where you are you really on
top of things you are this close to
doing this whole thing debt-free you've
almost hustled your way through it by
the way when do you graduate
right now accepted to graduate at about
2023 so 2020 so you're a freshman I'm
not sophomore but I'm looking at taking
about five years of classes why because
my first my first year of college I
essentially failed one semester what
classes between both semesters so I will
be retaking classes why did you fail it
was the money situation where I had to
work in order to pay off my just pay off
my living just survive basically and I
had us
I had a stupidly high rent back then two
Oaks Alice basically living off food
insurance and all that on like a hundred
fifty bucks a month I got to tell you
Alex you are you're doing a really good
job as a super young guy trying to wind
your way through this and figure figure
this out the lessons that you have
already learned and the lessons that you
are learning while you're plowing
through this are really going to set you
up for the next decade because you're
going to have some things that come out
of this like you know you realize the
stupid high rent now you and I are
talking you realizing this other gig
isn't paying you enough and we can do
this without student loan debt and
you've made a good choice in terms of a
field to study you've made a good choice
in terms of where to study it in state
tuition very reasonable tuition you know
you've made a lot of really good choices
and so you really are just about three
more good choices away from having this
thing on the run and I just want to
encourage you I'm I'm pretty impressed
with you you've fought your way through
some crap to get to where you are and I
think you might be
and be able to play catch-up because
once you start getting your head around
the idea that I'm working crappy jobs
that pay well to get this to get these
tuition paid you're not gonna want to
stay in school any longer than necessary
because you're trapped in the crappy job
to get the tuition paid and you know in
this substandard college life that
you're living and so you're gonna want
to crank those classes up and get on out
of there
maybe sooner than you've got in your
head right now but yeah I think you're
doing really really good sir I think you
really are I'm looking in from the
outside I hear a lot of a lot of good
things and a lot of richness that you in
in the lessons that you have learned so
hold on I'm gonna have Kelly send you a
copy of of Anthony O'Neill's book a
debt-free degree I want you to jump on
Anthony's site and learn about applying
for scholarships and see how many of
those you can get every minute of your
waking spare time is not spent playing
beer pong it's spent applying for
scholarships and let's get through this
thing without any more debt and between
a better paying job you've already made
good college selection and then has some
scholarships to this you know we really
could see your whole situation turn
around dramatically so check Anthony
O'Neill comm the website out it's got a
really good scholarship search tool on
it he's got a bunch of other good things
on there having to do help students in
your situation and will send you a copy
of his number one best-selling book
debt-free degree which is what I'm
trying to walk you through and show you
how to do but dude you were just this
close and you figured it out on your own
because it's obvious that you are on
your own
so you're not anymore we got your back
brother you call here anytime that we
can help I'll help you any kind of any
way I can I like guys like you that are
scratching and clawing and hustling and
grinding you're gonna make it you're
gonna be alright brother you gonna be
alright